[Musique]
bonjour à la jimmy bonjour hervé mariton
bonjour bonjour vous êtes le président
de la fedom la fédération des
entreprises d outre-mer vous avez été
élu il ya justement il me semble 26 mai
oui 2021 avant de parler des raisons de
votre visite en martinique quelle
analyse faites vous du vote le pen dans
les outre mer dans une tribune publiée
dans le figaro vox vous expliquez que
les causes de ce vote sont sociales
économiques sécuritaires et identitaires
on voit bien puisque les électeurs dans
le plus grand nombre d outre-mer quelles
que soient les histoires des uns et des
autres sont passés d'un vote mélenchon
un vote le pen que c'est un vote de
protestation
et ce vote de protestation je fais
l'analyse que ça cause principale est en
partie sécuritaire en effet mais pour
l'essentiel économique et social un mal
être social lié au niveau de chômage je
ne vous apprends rien un niveau
extrêmement élevé de chômage des jeunes
en particulier et une situation
économique qui n'est pas satisfaisante
et c'est là où la fédération des
entreprises d'outre-mer que je préside
depuis bientôt un an a toute sa raison
d'être qui est de favoriser d'encourager
le développement économique des
outre-mer le développement des
entreprises pour le développement de
l'emploi pour l'amélioration la
situation de l'emploi on parle beaucoup
des problèmes de pouvoir d'achat et
c'est essentiel évidemment le poème de
pouvoir d'achat c'est aussi un problème
de revenus des gens parce que d'évidence
ci a pas d'emploi ou si les emplois ne
sont pas des emplois suffisamment
qualifiés et bien alors il ya moins de
ressources pour vivre plus à l'aise au
niveau au niveau de prove pauvreté aussi
dans ses territoires d'outre-mer qui est
aussi en augmentation mais un niveau de
pauvreté qui en effet pose problème et
qui est lui même totalement lié au
niveau de chômage et c'est pour ça que
nous souhaitons que cette situation
s'améliore par le développement des
entreprises en étant offensif sur un
sombre de sujets d'avenir la transition
énergétique par exemple mais il ya aussi
un enjeu tout à fait considérable à
faire en sorte que toute une partie de
nos concitoyens qui aujourd'hui sont
attributaires du rsa puisse
retire cette situation parce que le rsa
c'est tout de même pas top en terme de
pouvoir d'achat est tout simplement de
chemin dans la vie le président les
revenus et le président république dans
sa campagne a dit qu'il réfléchissait à
être plus attentifs à ce que peuvent
être les contreparties au rsa je pense
qu'il ya un sujet qui est difficile
partout dans toute la france et aussi
difficile dans les outre-mers à la fedom
nous pensons qu'il ya là un sujet sur
lequel nous devons travailler on est
aussi sur des territoires et c'est vrai
en martinique comme ailleurs où le
travail informel comme on dit
aimablement est assez répandue comment
est-ce qu'on peut sortir de ce travail
informel comment est-ce qu'on peut aider
à ce que des personnes qui sont pas tout
à fait dans le cadre de la loi puisse
s'y retrouver davantage de bain avec des
formules probablement simplifiée pour
intégrer les circuits de l'économie mais
je pense que il ya un champ là dessus
très bien nous allons y revenez heureux
tout au long de cette interview pour
vous il faut une nouvelle politique pour
les autres maires des réformes
structurelles ça devrait passer par quoi
ce type de réformes qui nous sommes
favorables à une loi de programmation
pour le développement économique des
outre-mer mail y en a déjà eu il y en a
déjà eu l ont donné un son de résultats
on a déploré il ya quelques jours le
décès de bernard pons qui a été ministre
des dom-tom la line dance qu'alsace oui
bernard pons a engagé un mouvement
qu'est qu'un mouvement intelligent et
efficace avec la défiscalisation ce qui
a permis de créer de l'activité de créer
des emplois il a pu y avoir des abus il
a pu y avoir des détournements ça fait
partie de la vie de la responsabilité de
l'état et nous sommes prêts à
l'accompagner de faire en sorte qu'il
n'y ait pas d'abus et de détournement
d'ailleurs les choses ont été
sérieusement encadrée depuis mais ça a
été un mouvement intelligent le
président république parle de
programmation énergétique et bien chiche
quand il parle de programmation
énergétique je pense qu'on doit aussi
sur un enjeu aussi considérable que
celui du développement des entreprises
du développement de l'économie du
développement de l'emploi de la solution
du problème de chômage dans les
outre-mers qu'on doit pouvoir parler de
programmation d'où notre proposition
d'une loi de programmation pour
développement économique des outre-mer
vraiment notre conviction la mienne
aussi personnellement c'est que
l'enjeu principal des outre mer c'est
l'économie non pas parce que on a le
culte du veau d'or et que ce serait
l'économie pour l'économie mais parce
que le développement d'économies est à
la clé du mieux-être du mieux vivre de
tous nos concitoyens sur le plan social
tout simplement dans leur vie c'est pas
les développeurs
à la situation de l'emploi est ce qu'il
ne faut pas aujourd'hui changer de
paradigme quand on voit ce qui s'est
passé avec la crise du coup vic 19 ou
toute une partie de l'économie a été
bloqué est ce qu'aujourd'hui il faut pas
réfléchir à une économie plus proche du
territoire mais oui l'économie doit être
plus proche du territoire oui il y à des
changements de paradigme et la loi de
programmation doit être l'occasion de
réfléchir à cela oui davantage de
responsabilités et d'adaptation au
terrain il y a dans la loi de la
république aujourd'hui des possibilités
d'adaptation norma qu'ils savent a dû
pouvoir dérogatoire des préfets à
l'habilitation législatives des
collectivités vous le savez il y a très
peu de mise en oeuvre de ses
possibilités outre-mer si tu aimes assez
curieux on est dans un pays la france où
les systèmes sont souvent trop rigide
mais temps en temps il ya des
possibilités d'adaptation qui sont
créées ces adaptations elles ne sont pas
mises en oeuvre il y a eu en martinique
quelques habilitation législative mais
très peu en vérité et à la marge pas sur
les enjeux les plus lourds eh bien oui
si on veut développer l'économie vous
évoquez tout à l'heure à l'antenne les
craintes du btp si l'on veut améliorer
la situation dans le btp on a besoin
d'un sombre d'adaptation normative et la
fedom travail à ça c'est un exemple
concret du travail que l'on mène pour
les entreprises et pour la vie
économique des outre mer justement vous
allez rencontrer serge de timides qui a
entamé cette démarche déjà devra de
rassembler en congrès pour pouvoir
développer les habilitations mais aller
au delà sur les habilitations ça me
semble avoir du sens moi je dis
simplement une chose et nous en
parlerons dans la semaine avec le
président letchimy je respecte sa
démarche il est élu du suffrage
universel moi je suis simplement un
représentant d'entreprises nous
travaillons avec nos adhérents sur le
terrain qui ont pleine légitimité à
mener leur action que ce soit le medef
que soit la cci que ce soit les
organisations patronales que ce soit la
hem pays dans le domaine de l'industrie
d'autres organisations d'employeurs
c'est elle qui sont en première ligne
dans la discussion avec la collectivité
territoriale et bien sûr je rencontre le
président c'est la moindre des choses et
je respecte sa mission et quand il parle
des lois d'habilitation je pense qu'il a
raison de regarder sujet parce qu'il ya
un champ sur lequel des progrès
considérables je pense doivent être
accomplis je dis simplement une chose
vous avez évoqué ma tribune je le dis
faisons attention je crois vraiment que
l'énergie doit être concentré
aujourd'hui sur les enjeux économiques
et je ne voudrais pas que les enjeux
institutionnels gomme le reste il ya
toujours des progrès des habilitations
mais pas pour une des formes
institutionnelles mais s'il y a des
progrès importants à faire sur ce
terrain pourquoi pas mais vraiment la
réforme institutionnelle il faut pas que
ce soit pour le plaisir de la réforme
institutionnelle je suis convaincu que
les élus ont suffisamment de maturité
pour ne pas tomber dans ce piège là et
qui pourrait aussi être un piège de
l'état d'ailleurs en passant parce que
pendant qu'on parle de ça on parle pas
d'autre chose l'enjeu principal
aujourd'hui ce que notre sitruk nos
concitoyens ou crier au monde l'élection
présidentielle c'est bien qu'il ya un
problème social ce problème est un
problème économique ce problème est un
problème d'emploi avant d'être une
question institutionnelle si la réforme
institutionnelle permet de faire des
progrès dans le domaine économique on
prend six et le débat si chanel pour
débat institutionnel et ben alors ça
peut être du gaspillage d'énergie une
pièce de l'étain vous dites quand le
bleu mise d outre mer va en guadeloupe
et parle d'autonomie c'est le piège non
je pense que ce n'était pas un piège
mais je pense qu'il faut faire attention
et je pense que quand le ministre dit
cela il envoie la balle aux acteurs de
la guadeloupe mais il ne résout pas la
totalité des sujets qui sont à l'ordre
du jour donc c'est aussi aux acteurs de
terrain les élus ici les élus politiques
les responsables économiques et nous
modestement dans notre rôle en tant que
fait l'homme dans le conseil qu'on peut
apporter et le relais qu'on peut
apporter sur le plan national de dire
qu'il y a un enjeu principal c'est
l'amélioration de la situation sociale
économique des territoires ça passe par
le développement des entreprises par la
création d emplois que si le débat
institutionnel y compris que quand il
est lancé par ministre permet de faire
des progrès sur ce terrain là ça se
prend il faut pas que ce soit les
institutions pour les institutions et
pendant ce temps là on ne s'occupe pas
de ce qui préoccupe principalement nos
concitoyens autre thème autres thèmes
d'importance l'octroi de mer voyez que
fait-on de leur poids de berre il faut
supprimer l'octroi de mer aujourd'hui je
comprends que le gouvernement a envie on
verra ce qu'il en est au final de
d'ouvrir le débat sur ce terrain là nous
savons aussi tout simplement parce
qu'ils nous ont demandé à nous
rencontrer que les membres de la cour
des comptes envisage de lancer un
travail sur ce sujet c'est pas la
première fois vous savez comme moi se
débat depuis l'octroi de mer existe il
est posé régulièrement et c'est
totalement légitime qu'il soit posé
simplement nous ce que nous disons c'est
que les choses peuvent bouger elles
peuvent bouger si c'est pour aller dans
un mieux un mieux pour les consommateurs
la lutte contre la vie chère un mieux
aussi pour les entreprises l'enjeu qu'il
y a à défendre les entreprises et en
patrouille dans le domaine de la
production parce que c'est important
qu'il y ait une production sur le
territoire et on sait que ce sujet est
un peu compliqué aujourd'hui parce que
l'octroi de mer c est aussi une
ressource pour les collectivités locales
est-ce que c'est raisonnable d'avoir le
même outil qui soit ressources pour les
collectivités locales et outils de
protection pour les industriels ça se
travaille ça se regarde dernier point si
je peux me permettre c'est qu'il y a
pour l'octroi de mer des possibilités de
différencier les taux d'octroi de mer
selon les produits qu à la réunion par
exemple sur le département de la réunion
il ya davantage de taux de
différenciation pardon des taux d'octroi
de mer selon la nature des produits
qu'il n'est pratiqué en martinique mais
c'est vrai aussi en guadeloupe il ya un
chantier là dessus je crois d'ailleurs
que la créativité territoriale de
martinique et que les acteurs
économiques de martinique se sont d'ores
et déjà emparée de ce chantier voilà
monsieur mariton la première partie de
notre émission terminée